[Musique]
des résultats qui donnent l'image d'une
france coupée en 5 signe d'une société
éclatée pour ne pas dire déboussolé un
scrutin en tout cas caractérisée par un
important vote protestataire ce matin
tous les journaux ont mis en avant la
surprise du premier tour l'échappée
belle de l'île aux dauphins pour
reprendre l'expression de nos confrères
de libération france art voix
[Musique]
après le vote des électeurs de métropole
les départements et territoires
d'outre-mer et des français de
l'étranger les résultats officiels du
premier tour sont lionel jospin 7
millions sans 2018 voix 23 et le 30 août
sans les suffrages
jacques chirac qui 6 millions 351 1950
et une voix 20 84 % des suffrages
edouard balladur 100 millions six cent
soixante deux mille 124 voix
18,58 % des suffrages
[Applaudissements]
jean-marie le pen quatre millions cinq
cent soixante treize mille deux cent
cinquante deux voies 15% des suffrages
[Musique]
robert hue deux millions six cent trente
quatre mille 187 voix
8,64 % des suffrages
arlette laguiller un million six cent
seize 1566 bois
50% des suffrages
philippe de vignes et un million quatre
cent quarante 4082 voix
4,74 % des suffrages
dominique voynet 1 million
11490 voix 3 32% des suffrages
[Musique]
et jacques jacques cheminade
85000 186 voix
0,28 pour cent des suffrages
le conseil constitutionnel proclamera
ses résultats avant 20 heures mercredi
ainsi s'achève le vote les premiers
tours
[Musique]